oui
[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interwiew nous
sommes avec monsieur mahamat saleh
annadif représentant spécial et chef de
la mission intégrée multidimensionnelle
des nations unies pour la stabilisation
au mali la minus ma un entretien
exclusif monsieur annadif merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
la minustah et compte au moins quatorze
mille militaires et policiers déployés
au mali elle a connu de nombreuses
pertes depuis 2013 au moins 200 hommes
comment fait elle fasse d'abord merci
pour l'occasion et je sais qu on dise
paris et y j'ai une pensée pieuse
il n'a pas dit comment nous faisons face
vous savez c'est une mission de paix des
nations unies
mais la vérité c'est qu'elle évolue dans
un environnement difficile caractérisé
par la présence des terroristes mais
nous continuons à nous adapter face au
point que l'on ne sont pas restés
localisés dans l'autre nous continuons à
faire des pâtes lui nous continuons à
améliorer notre formation en matière d
engins explosifs improvisés parce que la
majeure partie de nos pertes
malheureusement conviennent des chr nous
continuons prêts à nous adapter
malheureusement nous avons un ennemi un
ennemi invisible
un ennemi qui ne connaît pas de
frontières qui ne connaît que l'art la
vitalité qui est là pour faire du mal et
lui aussi sa date avec les nouvelles
il s'adapte mais grâce à notre
détermination nous sommes en train d'y
faire face
les fêtes font partie de ce genre
d'émission qui sont quand même assez
risqué mais nous disons qu'on est là
deux sets au style sécuritaire nous
disons toujours que les pays dans
lesquels c'était ce qu'ils et elles
persistent doit aller au delà de la
réponse sécuritaire et chercher à savoir
les causes profondes et certains vis tu
passeras le chômage des jeunes qui
passent par le sous-développement et
donc sur toutes ces personnes au bal
nous sommes en train d'entreprendre
je le promets à 6 ans les missions des
nations unies allaient déployer au mali
depuis 2013 tout de même ses lourdes
pertes
est-ce qu'elles ne remettent pas en
cause d'une certaine façon le nom d'à de
la mini cement et heureusement que la
communauté internationale le conseil de
sécurité des nations unies mais aussi
les pays de police sont aujourd'hui
conscients que la menace terroriste est
une menace globale et que sa réponse
également doit être vue sous l'angle de
la solidarité
robin et chaque fois que le conseil de
sécurité s'est réuni nous avons une
résolution qui raconte l'unanimité de
ses membres étant qu au vu de ce débat
on au vu de cette vision
j'estime que la question de la remise en
cause du mandat n'est pas à l'ordre du
jour
l'exemple le plus récent je reviens de
la côte d'ivoire où pour la première
fois depuis le déploiement de la mission
nous avons effectué quatre jeunes
ivoiriennes je suis parti nous avons
fait la cérémonie où ce que je ne sais
pas vraiment ce que les ivoiriens sont
prêts à continuer dans la mission
ils sont déterminés à accompagner
le mali aurait trouvé la paix parce que
le raisonnement est que ceux qui
touchent le mali push la côte d'ivoire
et il faut combattre le marco tu vois on
allie éviter ça ça veut dire que le
mandat de la minus mahé proroger au-delà
de juin 2021
il ya de fortes chances qu'il peut
encore et toujours des ajustements et il
ya de fortes chances qu'il soit a
poursuivi il faut il y aller fortes
chances qu'ils soient les nouvelles et
ceux qui le sont dans une phase de
transition et dans une résolution du
conseil de sécurité une déclaration du
16 octobre de procéder sécurité à
l'unanimité acquis que la ministre mme
anthouard ont signé l'accord à vous
parliez de réajustement lesquelles par
exemple une augmentation par exemple des
des équipements nous avons un déficit
par exemple en couverture aérienne nous
rencontrent quelques difficultés à
matière de véhicules blindés
je suis sûr qu'ils vont lancer un appel
aux pays contributeurs de ou ou de
police ou des autres partenaires pour
qu' il y ait plus de capacité à ce
niveau alors il ya un contexte quand
même particulier c'est le contexte
sanitaire est ce que la pandémie qui
sévit également de plus en plus sur le
continent africain au mali a un impact
sur la mission des casques bleus le
constat global des cassettes pandemic à
main a touché tout le monde et tout le
monde
la minus mois en faire partie nous
sommes au mali la peau vite
disney a fait des dégâts au moins l
anafé légalement
de la milice mans on nous avons eu la
même beaucoup de cas positifs
heureusement notre cour de révision est
assez élevé nous avons perdu tout à
l'honneur de notre colère mais en
respectant les mesures barrières à
respecter le port du masque obligatoire
j'avais mal et je me dis qu'il faut la
paix sinon en général
tant que je suis dehors de rechargement
j'ai moment ça fait partie des scellés
sur et les manques et grâce à ces
mesures
autant mais il faut faire de cette
pandémie nous avons comme ans continue
de façon parallèle à exécuter notre
mandat à poursuivre notre mission tout
en prenant le soin ne puisse pas alors
on parlait des lourdes pertes
il ya quand même des succès en matière
d'opérations anti djihadistes mais on a
le sentiment que c'est une guerre
perpétuelle dans le sahel contre les
terroristes les groupes terroristes les
groupes jihadistes
quel est votre constat mais j'ai
toujours dit que le terrorisme est une
interview dans le corps il faut un
minimum de temps pour pouvoir les
dégager
et donc la lutte contre le terrorisme
doit être reçue dans le moyen et long
terme
mais j'ai dit également à comme je
l'avais dit tout à l'heure il est
extrêmement important au niveau mondial
ou un ego tu sais l on puisse penser à à
l'origine du mal à savoir les causes
profondes dont j'ai parlé et tout à
l'heure pour ce qui est des du magny jeu
toujours interpeller la classe politique
pour dire que quel que soit ce référé
les partenaires quels que soient ses
effets réels l'amusement
tant qu'il n'y a pas un consensus
national sur les principaux défis
on ne pourra pas s'en sortir la sous
région est en train de
mais l'exemple vous avez vu la situation
en côte d'ivoire
pour moi les ivoiriens sont en train de
discuter ou apaiser le climat
vous avez bien au niveau de la du
burkina faso comment les choses sont en
train de se passer nous avons l'exemple
du niger
c'est pour cela que j'ai dit que quel
que soit ce qu est le partenaire ferrer
ou la milice proférées j'ai toujours dit
il faut un sursaut national de la classe
politique hôtellerie s'entendre sur
l'essentiel à savoir la paix la
stabilité aux magny et c'est ça qui va
nous aider à mieux réaliser cette aide à
mieux
justement il ya une région qui retient
particulièrement l'attention qui
concentre les attaques ce dernier temps
c'est la région dite des trois
frontières mali burkina faso niger où on
y retrouve principalement deux groupes
actifs la affiliés à al qaïda al qaïda
au maghreb islamique et puis l'autre à
l'état islamique
l'état islamique au grand sahraouis gs
quel est concrètement leur influence
c'est vrai que les altérations diffèrent
les uns sont affiliés à pédales et est
la même pour m'en sers tous deux groupes
et terrorisme ce sont toujours de
groupes qui sont ennemis de la paix qui
sont pour la déstabilisation de cette
région du sahel la zone des trois
frontières conçu style le point où on ne
retrouvera plus nombreux parce que il
essaie de dissimuler au niveau de la
population
ils ont pris en otage la population
mais grâce à la coopération
internationale au niveau de cette région
paris ce qui se passe au niveau du côté
de basso on est au niveau de ce qui se
passe au niveau du niger depuis un
certain temps nous avons constaté que
les deux groupes se décentrer déchire
entre elles mêmes entre eux mêmes il se
vend une petite guéguerre pour moi c'est
pas ça les accords passés sont tous des
ennemis de la paix indépendamment de
leur idéologie
nous devons le bon bah c'est qu'ils sont
solidaires et avec des résultats assez
positif alors la minustah évolué au
sahel ou mali aux côtés d'autres forces
y ait la force barkan l'opération
française barkan il ya une réflexion
aujourd'hui pour réviser justement cette
les effectifs de l'opération barkan on
se dirige vers un allègement canton
c'est vous la décision d'un allégement
justement les gens justement cet
allégement aucune conséquence des
requêtes l'opération martin moi je vois
plutôt les succès qui part quand on est
ici pour niveau du du mali vous voyez on
ne le dira jamais assez mais
malheureusement on ne répètera au mois
de juin dernier
abdelmalek audelin qui est le grand
ennemi al qaïda au maghreb islamique a
été détruit
on en parle très peu avant lui il a des
chefs opérationnels tels que dément la
hague au logement tels que al ansary et
devenir moi un grand chef militaire qui
est même le chef d'état major des
pillages à cali a été neutralisée au
niveau
la zone justement des trois frontières
et les capacités opérationnelles malgré
les musculation par ci par là
nous qui sommes sur le terrain je
constate entière ces forces du mal ces
jeunes habitent là et connaissent
beaucoup de pères d'une perte
extrêmement important maintenant est par
cannette une opération militaire
elle opère dans une zone à risque
il est assez difficile qu'il y ait des
pertes ça fait partie pourquoi de la
nature même de la règle du jeu qu'elle
soit qu'elle sait les a juste qu'un
s'adapte je suis monsieur nadif nous
allons poursuivre dans un instant cet
entretien exclusif mais on va marquer
une courte pause et on se retrouve dans
un instant rester avec nous sur rt
france
[Musique]
retour dans la grande interview pour un
entretien exclusif avec monsieur mahamat
saleh annadif représentant spécial de
d'antonio goûteux reste le patron de
l'onu et chef de la minustah la mission
des nations unies au mali
monsieur n a dit on évoqué le retrait
probable de des militaires de barkan de
plusieurs militaires de barkan c'est ce
qui est envisagé en tout cas par la
france qu'elle pourrait être selon vous
tout de même les conséquences d'une
révision des effectifs de l'opération
française de l'effectif ce qui est passé
l'argent c'est la solidarité
aujourd'hui les nouvelles technologies
et vous l'avez constaté un avion qui est
à paris dans le 2 ou 3 heures des super
intervenir dans cette région du sahel
donc moi au delà de l'éduction des
réajustements de chargement de posture
ce qui est vraiment important pour moi
c'est la solidarité c'est la continuité
dans l'engagement et ça c'est la chose
pour le président français manuel macron
on ne discute pas je le cite avec les
terroristes
on combat un ce que d'une certaine façon
de partager son avis partagé les guerres
les batailles on finit toujours par des
discussions par des négociations
je crois que c'est qui ces dix et qui
sait au délà des des nuances et la cua
roubles aperam est une illustration dès
qu'il ya une volonté pour eux faire la
paire il faut qu'elle avait soir tendue
et je crois que de ce point de vivre
toutes les déclamations concours à qui
il faut faire la paix avec qui sont avec
ceux qui sont disposés pour la faire et
de ce point de vue je crois que ce que
disent les manières et disent les autres
et un synthétiseur les français au delà
de la sémantique pour tous tous à la
recherche d'une paix tu l'as de la
stabilité et qu' il faut tout faire pour
que les gens prennent oms à la mûre ans
blonde russie et qui s'il ya des jeunes
qui sont embrigadés qui sont en outre
signé qui sont en tout cas un trompe et
il faut les aider à retrouver une vie
normale et que ce jeu-là venir bien ne
devoir être épargné pour les ramener
mais quand il ya des prises d'otages on
sait qu'il ya des négociations ou est-ce
qu'il faut placer les limites
vous avez évoqué il ya des algues ali
qui est
le chef du groupe de soutien à l'islam
et aux musulmans qui avait enlevé le sou
mais là si c'est l'opposant malien la
française aussi sophie petrona et deux
italiens ils ont été relâchés à l'issue
de négociations ou est-ce qu'il faut
placer les limites la limite à quelque
chose des traits d très difficile mais
j'ai dû tout simplement que pour faire
la paix il faut être à deux ok la
volonté exprimée par les maliens ou par
d'autres partenaires soient également
accepté par l'autre partie maintenant
pour ce qui est de la position du mal
hier la bande à le manier les mots date
estime qu' il y a pouf a sondé ma vie et
il se trouve dans une nébuleuse
internationale terroristes et qui
souriait les possibilités pour négocier
avec les maliens pour empêcher ce cycle
infernal qui n'effectue coûter cher aux
maris tic fille qui en deux il les
familles maliennes
il faut couper ce cordon ombilical qui
lie les locaux assez me plaisent
internationale des sages qui font qu'il
a donné raison ce sera la condition et
de l'autre côté les gallois ont
manifesté alors vous savez que le gsm
jihad el ghali essaie de surfer aussi
sur un sentiment anti français par
exemple mais aussi contre la présence
militaire étrangère ou au sahel
on sait qu'il ya une certaine opinion
publique qui juge cette présence
inefficace face à l'insécurité
comment est ce qu'on prend le dessus
dans cette guerre de communication avec
ces groupes jihadistes
malheureusement avec aujourd'hui les
outils de communication qui existent
avec les détenus aux héros il est
difficile de distinguer dit vrai et
qu'il faut mais je crois qu'il faut il
faut continuer il faut continuer à aider
c'est tu peux aller vers la paix a à les
réaliser il faut continuer c'est une
campagne c'est une autre forme de guerre
médiatique il faut soudier faut avoir
les éléments hors la gagner et elles
peuvent être gagnés c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui les choses sont très
sophistiqués
aujourd'hui les moyens qu'ils utilisent
et les cafés sont susceptibles de même
par ces terroristes
quand on sait aujourd'hui qu'ils sont
capables d'utiliser des drones qui sont
capables d utiliser des plateformes qui
sont basées partout dans le monde
équipés peur aux coupes du mal il faut
analyser un combat qui mérite quand même
d'être engagé et où la solidarité la
coopération de partenariat
en tout cas le duo mais aussi la france
de nombreux pays africains ouest
africains soutiennent l'accord d'alger
et a été signé en 2015 qui prévoit un
dialogue entre les différents groupes
politiques et autonomistes où en est sa
mise en oeuvre puisque la minus maha
joue un rôle important dans la mise en
oeuvre de cet accord d'alger
j'ai toujours dit qu'elle est là j'ai
fait partie de la solution
il n'aime pas la solution une île
il ne vous dit rien
il ya une confiance qui s'est rétabli
il ya une volonté politique qui est la
clé principale pour sa mise en oeuvre
qui se consolide mais parallèlement à sa
mise en orbite également qu'il y ait des
réformes politiques et institutionnelles
il faut qu'il y ait des réformes au
niveau interface et sécurité il faut
surtout qu'il y ait des réformes au
niveau de l'appareil judiciaire pour
éviter que les mêmes causes ne
produisent pas les mêmes effets parce
que cette crise au niveau du nord une
crise qui a trop dit réel à elle a
commencé dans les années 60 elle se
perpétue
elle compte unis comme en mai ce cycle
infernal rébellion réconciliation
rébellion je sais que la seule façon
c'est aborder cette question avec
beaucoup de courage et surtout avec
détermination pour engager les réformes
nécessaires dit il qui sont plus vides à
la porte de la paix est au point que je
lui ai dit que cette solution n'est pas
l'unique solution il puisse être la
locomotive du terrain et résoudre ou
qu'il y ait une solution qui embrasse
tous les aspects et qu'elle soit c'est
tout une solution durable
le sel c'est quand même on va le
préciser c'est une zone vaste comme
l'europe il ya la minus ma barkan le g5
sahel la mission européenne de formation
de l'armée malienne le thème mali et
puis la task force européenne takouba
comment cet ensemble se coordonnent
justement coordonne ses actions sur le
terrain là c'est différent ce qui est
solidaire d'extrêmement la majorité mais
c'est faux ça peut vous venez d
d'énumérer ont un mandat du conseil du
conseil de sécurité des nations unies et
nous avoir côté des forces de défense et
sécurité maliennes chacun a son mandat
mais nous avons pas mal d organe de
coordination
c'est lui qui lui au niger espace de
compilation romagne qui fait des
réunions périodiques au niveau de
commandement des différents seront
présents et qui jusqu'à la vie ici plus
ou moins à maintenir cet élan de
coordination qui est indispensable
nécessaire pour plus d'efficacité les
dunes d'écault région jusqu'à là ça
s'est fait rouler dessus vous savez que
certains pays comme le niger plaide
aussi pour une coalition internationale
contre les djihadistes au sahel
pourquoi ce n'est pas cette option
finalement qui est retenu à l'onu de
lancer l'idée d'une coalition
internationale
intégré à la réflexion contre
l'extrémisme violent ou le retour de la
paix pour ça elle n'est pas terminée les
débats renouveau du conseil de sécurité
sur contout on est unis au niveau des
sirènes également les gens ne sont pas
aussi la mise en place de la force
rejointe jeux sexuels tels exemples
palpables ou voilà cinq pays de celle de
la sous région
au delà de l'international au delà du
partenariat se sont entendus pour créer
une synergie en mettant ensemble leur
rapacité et pour dire qu'avant de
compter sur les autres on doit compter
sur nous
cette volonté politique mérite d'être
accompagné d'être soutenue parce que la
lutte contre le terrorisme coûte cher et
demande des moyens et d'équipements
sophistiqués
la communauté internationale doit être
prête à accompagner cet engagement
politique du si des différents chefs
d'état il ya aussi une réflexion pour
proposer une réponse économique aussi à
l'insécurité avec ce fameux projet de la
muraille verte qui a été reprise par le
président français emmanuel macron la
muraille verte est une idée de l'union
africaine elle été pensé par des les
appliquer aux dire que la deuxième
division compliquer le problème la
désertification fait en sorte ces
régions sont dépeuplés l'économie est
ravagée et qu'il faut plutôt intégrer la
dimension économique résilience
construction des moyens de transports et
de communications et je dois quand je
parlais tout à l'heure des causes aux
rondes
j'ai parlé du sous-développement de la
marginalisation de la discrétion de
chômage qui touche les jeunes global qui
doit être lancé l'idée de la mer et tu
n'hésitais pas de l'union africaine
soutient je suis juste une dernière
question assez rapidement monsieur
maladie sans la situation politique au
mali vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure ce
qui est une chance de voir des élections
se tenir au mali dans un délai de 14
mois comme
il a été décidé notamment avec les pays
de la communauté économique des états
d'afrique de l'ouest
j'ai dû toujours que la transition
actuelle au monde offre une fenêtre
d'opportunité pour sortir de ce cycle
infernal ouganda élections ou guetta et
1 ci dessus et donc pour s'en sortir
un consensus national est nécessaire
nous poussons nos frères maliens ou d
encourageant parce que la classe
politique
il est important qui vient ce sursaut d
importants que on s'entend dessous les
minimes ont offensé les réformes
nécessaires utiles qui puisse amener les
maliens à avoir des élections mais pas
n'importe quelle élection pour que ces
élections soient crédibles
il faut que les résultats issus de ces
élections soient acceptables
il faut que les autorités issues de ces
élections est un minimum de légitimité
je donne toujours l'exemple du burkina
faso burkina faso vient définir des
élections elle a su qu'au niveau du nord
il est impossible d'organiser des
élections pour att
mais la classe politique s'est assise et
l a dit et non une loi qui fasse en
sorte que on dise que les élections même
si elle ne se développe un hollow son
volant
c'est une prise de conscience incroyable
qui sourit elle a permis que des
élections se déroulent les résultats
sont donnés tout le monde a répondu
aujourd'hui l'ancien chef de file de
l'opposition a été nommé ministre en
charge de la réconciliation nationale
mais ces bons exemples comme ça qu'est
nos frères maliens doivent cible et on
en a besoin on est ainsi on les
encourage et j'espère qu il faut pas
être fataliste les appliquer les uns des
liens les maliens sont capables d'une
telle
réflexion de 7,5 m
monsieur mahamat saleh annadif merci
beaucoup pour cet entretien exclusif
accordé à rtl france rappelle que vous
êtes le représentant spécial du
secrétaire général de l'onu et le chef
de la minustah
[Musique]
merci encore à vous et merci à vous
d'avoir suivi cette grande interview une
grande interview que vous pouvez
retrouver en intégralité sur nos réseaux
sociaux et sur notre site internet
rt france point tva très bientôt
[Musique]